and that previous episode
Hausa go breath my name and welcome back
to some separation but beyond two souls
that's confetti here more Tessa yeah
Edgar just pull me to concentrate Jody
tell me if you feel anything in
particular about any of these subjects
what kind of test is this why are they
tissues they're one he wasn't even doing
with those tissues I know what boys do
with dishes they cry okay that
doesn't do anything for me
the best police badge no that's not what
I click for memories Anna Nana Nana Nana
Nana and memory Alan pretty well you
okay I'm fine
I'm fine did you see something
I saw a little girl
it was her music box
was it his daughter yeah he lost his
daughter huh
yeah Nathan okay although I like that
she gets away with murdering people
Nathan no one gives a name Ryan Clayton
is here to see you says you know what
it's about
yes I'll be back in a moment you're
right there daddy Dafoe is it all good
in the hood
we can play with those tissues now
what are we supposed to do just walk
around
go ahead Ryan God let's fire on him
listen and then I'll attempt get around
to telling her I need more time
no professor docking she needs to come
with me today I I have my orders Christ
she's suddenly a child my assistant and
I are the only family she's got she
doesn't have any idea what's out there
look Dawkins I see your side of it all
right I do
the orders are orders right you're gonna
bring her to me or do I have to go and
get her gosh what a dick
Jody could you come here please
I know what it's about don't
patronize me can we escape
I don't even get to say goodbye to my
friend it's not it with you what's
what's going on next you know what's
going on you look upset
Jodi this is Ryan Clayton from the CIA
the agents the agency wants you to join
their military school program at Camp
Perry Ryan's gonna take care of you from
now on you have to go with them Jodi
today
why understand
why me this unit belongs to the CIA
they've been tracking your case ever
since you arrived they know what you and
Aiden can do angry
what am i a towaway some kind of a test
subject did you ever just stop and think
about what I want I know it's difficult
but you need to understand this is a
great opportunity for you ah
Paul I don't care what you think
I'm not going anywhere Jesus listen up
miss Holmes I don't give a about
your pathetic adolescent pouting all
right
you can rant and rave all you want just
shut your mouth and do as you're told
consult that 88 yourself yeah
that's right
let's go come on you want to fight
me huh
you sure about that
stop immediately
[Music]
[Applause]
what Jody she's gonna get a break you
know what I mean
all are the essentials we've got
everything you need a cat berry Camp
Perry huh we've seen how that goes I
like the idea that you know I make these
decisions back in time and that changes
the future time or the real time but at
the same time it feels kind of like I
know what's gonna happen it's gonna go
to the camp anyway it's like it
kind of kind of kills a little bit of
what's gonna happen next
yeah now I just feel like I'm doing
stuff to continue the story no feel like
oh what's gonna happen I don't know what
are you what are we gonna kick pack
there's our bag let's get mr. the pizza
no pizza is not essential last time I
checked but who knows these days
I need my bed no cry Jodi Hey Judy don't
cry can't peek is great you kind of get
a new haircut you can learn how to
kick ass learn how to show was
balls you know mr. faught fade does not
contribute to that last one bit
yeah we're bringing mr. fluffy come on
military training camp course we're
bringing mr. fluffy that all we're
bringing how many things you need leave
sake I realize the soundtrack of
this game though
[Music]
don't worry I'm sure you'll be great
she's so sure I'm gonna miss the hell
out of you princess
[Music]
I come and see you as soon as I can I've
never let you down
you know that
[Music]
I'd only be there for you understand
those two
time to go
I think daddy defo was gonna die what
are you missing that I oh whoa daddy
Devils hangs on Jaden
Norman s that's a muse and noun
adjective
[Music]
okay I like that was over that was
the dinner okay
I don't know III can tell you this I
really enjoyed more the desert part
because it was more like a thing by
itself you know seven movies ends I
really liked less appointment and it
built character - there's not Auto I'm
just talking about my head now MA
well that's hot huh hey it's Ryan
you one Ryan I was just wondering
if you got my email who reads me what
what do you know
while I spend three days ago yeah don't
go you don't shank internet I've
actually been having problems with my
computer what was the email about dinner
tonight fancy restaurant anyway it's too
late now so maybe another time it's
gonna get dressed
I'm so sorry I know why don't
you just come over here for dinner
tonight
that's a terrible like if you wanted to
see my apartment anyway so um sure but
how about around 8:00 okay yeah I'll
bring a kick-ass bottle of wine see you
later kick-ass a bottle of wine kick-ass
a bottle of aim having a healthy head of
hey how much do you like this guy huh ah
God God I gotta clean up for this idiot
well no I didn't bust on my computer
you didn't want me to see Ryan what I'm
sorry it's just I he's no good your call
I didn't Wow well maybe it is well well
maybe you can't cuz I'm here too and I
don't want you around those again I'm
not starting if there's I didn't I'm a
dad relationship with whoever I want
sure this is my life do you hear
me this is my life I heard you your life
get it get it get it got it got it
jeez well I happen to think Ryan is
great Ryan is a trap intelligent
he's funny
hey that's me you described me right
they think I'm sorry for him
that is big no no no not Ryan I'm aware
of what happened at the bar yeah what
happened at the bar he touched your tit
Ryan is not like that
yeah yes they are like don't make me
fatty seven o'clock
I got one hour to get dressed put makeup
dinner tidy up okay so God do I have to
clean out Oh God No thank God
it's a montage the trash can in the
kitchen yeah yeah thanks for reminding
yourself that is like these are being
laws of physics what the all right
let's cook done what is that
you gotta get drunk yeah you gotta get a
little snappy snoop on if you're gonna
go on a date you know I'm saying you got
a good you gotta get your buzz off you
know I'm saying yeah this is a little
bit just maybe you don't wanna you know
you want oh that wasn't water oh oh yeah
yeah yeah you wanna get a little
was on girl I bet he's gonna commentate
it if we up
yes that is how you could be nailed it
that's how my girlfriend cleans okay
just kidding she's lovely
anyway and how do i I saw something
there how do i oh I can just check that
running out of time don't panic now
now don't panic now what is that my
porno collection better best hide it yes
hide all of my porn hurry
books yes whatever you want to call it
yes a nice bookshelf just put up man
what's wrong with you just boom that
great yeah some I like your idea of
hiding your point hood no one dinner
there's got to be something in the
kitchen
don't worry about it we got clean your
glass already closed guys get in the
bathroom in the basket in the bathroom
that's what no one even said she's a bit
of a flash sir what you live I wonder I
you should probably you should probably
take a shower ice ice I sure I I want to
clean up properly like if I have guests
it's not gonna be dirty all right all
right
make the bed is that what you're gonna
do make the bed yeah no you don't need
to make me beg what are you doing moment
oh god oh god that late that was 45
minutes
you're like the slowest cleaner in the
entire you let us take a shower
education you be clean
I'm bible' Thank You shaky shaky shaky
shaky shaky shaky shaky
I always dry my legs first always no
matter what always fat your legs first
never know what's gonna happen otherwise
all right what should we wear this is
what usually takes 45 minutes for women
that would actually make sense you know
let's see how quick she does that we're
gonna strap on the bra that no that
would be funny
what do you run away I think this is
pretty appropriate yep let's go to
change oh sorry I thought silly me
well how she uses that stressed voice -
it's like I gotta change you never know
what's gonna happen okay why should we
wear breast cells I I would say
something sexy
cuz it's her flight after all they're
like as you might have bored
I've been waiting for you that is that
is that looks sexier than the other one
[Laughter]
fine take a seat
god I knew me and it shows that I can
adapt to any situation you want to wear
that no
what oh I don't I might as well just
give up iDEN okay
this date is going on period
oh god I forgot about the food crap crap
he's early
uh I'm not waiting coming I'm not
wearing shoes are those shoes am I gonna
go barefoot it and it's Jens so awkward
uh one second
uh it's past like half an hour
now if it's like the ring oh god you're
not you never go early if you're on a
good date err haters that was that iDEN
you see doing a trick on us yeah he's
gonna do it
oh good one item okay you got me now
open the door I didn't come on open up
what can I do here whoa I never seen
this many buttons heavy rain you had to
do like 505 of em I can play too
oh nice nosebleed there though that's
pretty up I didn't know that was
like coke in your drink there what are
we doing okay kitchen right Gibson right
it's kind of hard to orient it is with
these angles what is this and I don't
normally set the table before I set the
plates but you know what are you gonna
cook down
she gonna cook that what you gonna cook
what you gonna cook though what you're
gonna cook what you gonna cut what you
gonna cook though what you gonna cook
what you gotta cut what you gonna call
mean something I can make in one hour
with whatsoever left in the fridge okay
too bad we have like five minutes though
they should be fun
I mean that looks good it's not too
complicated no I want the most cop the
chicken with oven baked vegetables I
have to take some time in the oven but
seems doable
it looks good bad you know it's not
exactly gourmet but no preparation no
mess I mean it could be an option and
what should we do the chicken curry
chicken curry yeah down-home flavor I
need all of that yeah you're gonna
it off okay
so how do you do it you press X oh god
we have ten minutes don't worry we're
fine we're fine all right
paprika yes chicken yes that chicken
looks good then you chop chop chop at
the top top a Papa Papa Dipper foot
okay dad now you're scanning don't date
him
don't do it Thanks
thanks Ally appreciate it
thanks I didn't gosh you're awkward
sometimes Dodie hey who did your nails I
must say they look mighty fine
got a lemon
no it's an onion oh you cry chori chori
arms chopped what we got next the
chicken now the chicken has bacteria on
it so you want to be careful with it so
you don't get you know what you have to
wash your hands afterward and you can't
mix it with the other food just like
Jody did but she I guess Jody don't give
a
you should never cut the chicken on the
same board as the other stuff you could
see really see it get touched good no so
far is it terrible you're gonna poison
him god I guess it's alright if you cook
it all of it
take an oven dish take an emendation
what the hell does that even mean girl
this is cook like a bow us
did you forget something Jodi you may
think I don't know what I'm doing well
isn't it past eight yeah the he's
late it's perfect all right leave that
chair for some reason okay how about oh
that's what we need yeah it cooks in the
oven all right then you're done actually
doesn't matter I take back what I said
my bad my bad my bad my bad my bad my
bad my bad my bad I'm up here I'll just
shut up good
my butt is asleep sitting in a weird
position a lot of bugs here in the scene
I don't know if you noticed it yet oh
yeah sure that's how it works much how
much of that do you need exactly I guess
she likes a lot of spice a lot of curry
and add some salt salt salt
better salt that with my salty
stick alright I'll be enough no pepper
looks like there is pepper that already
anyway in the oven we go are we cooking
with that using
all right now it's a probably hasn't
come yet you know you're wasting your
time I didn't uh-huh stop me from seeing
Ryan hey you're not what are you doing I
just like stacking chairs what's the
matter with you ah so romantic lightning
Lala la la la I love you baby
yeah that's very funny I didn't yeah
here yeah yeah watch
well it's very romantic ahead Ryan let's
check on our ass do
he's so late what he doesn't
come or something whoa she has his fancy
flat but she doesn't have a dish wash
machine no way now I'm just doing stuff
because it thank God
dick idiot
kill us come on I didn't don't be a pain
in the ass affect anything
alright that's open for him is this that
I can never like tell
I didn't behave yourself this was
important to me and I'm counting him why
he's a douche all right he's late
it's 40-minute lay my wine Venipede
kick-ass uh Chateau Margot 2001 good hey
it was a pretty good year that sounds
good to me
pretty good sounds pretty good to me
sorry sorry actually I'm not sorry let's
kill him
hey walked right into our trash um I'll
get the the thing that opens the wine
okay actually how long does this need to
be in there we didn't put it apartment
huh yeah yeah thanks gosh I didn't want
seats as if he didn't hear that
yes now let's get us some wine and get
of course of course it brings wine of
course of course of course
Maine Maine oh there it is
I wouldn't really thought that we were
doing it's really hard to control cuz
she like stops or whatever no no no I'll
do it
you're gonna cork it but okay fine not
bad Jodi not bad at all do you new
apartment
yes okay very nice very nice ah the chat
oh my chair did you move in it tastes
like your eggs um a couple weeks ago the
agency found it for me and all furnished
done everything which is actually the
first place I've ever had just by myself
that's weird
getting used to the idea so I can decide
to mess it up and how about you where
where do you live oh but I had the
choice not to a town that's small but
you know it's got a little garden it's
pretty quiet through the phone
awkward and did you did you grow up here
no I was born in Oregon now my parents
and brothers girl lived there I moved
out when I was I don't want to mess up
their day I'd be an probably you
know I'm gonna go check on the dinner
because this cooking thing it's a whole
new adventure for me you need help no
but when you go sit and more wine would
be okay mmm it smells good
oh it's some chicken curry with oven
baked vegetables um that's what it's
supposed to be this I didn't know you
cooked it looks great
mmm good well did you like it never get
another you didn't working together now
for what two years I mean almost nothing
about Joe I mean there's nothing much to
say I grew up with my parents on the DPA
campus and then and then Nathan looked
after me and well you pretty much know
the rest yeah your parents do you uh you
still see him no no no I don't I think
they were just terrified about how
different I was so Nathan and Cole they
they brought me up more or less they
taught me how to cope with item how to
accept myself as I am I mean it wasn't
always easy but I'm making progress
don't you thank God that the radar
I've got I didn't so i mean anyone in
our world you know what i didn't kind of
as always made people run away or maybe
it's me maybe I'm just too odd for
anyone to be interested in special Jodie
mmm
it's got nothing to do with this ah ah
God why no no God get room God God gosh
darn it dad yeah me finish your meal at
least no they're not gonna do what I
know no I I don't participate in this
sex sexual began extravaganza no look
away you look you look don't look dad
don't no don't don't
[Music]
what's the matter
thank God I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's not um oh hey your God
there's just hey there's some things
that I gave her
oh no oh no no poor Jodi No
[Music]
hey you just leave her
idiot
you can't just leave her just cuz you
didn't get what well that's for the
better than in my opinion it is such
such an night session okay so I
think if you prevented of if you didn't
go out that night she probably would
have hard-on Kodaka don't go do the
bottom up okay address I'm gonna have to
accept cert here Oh pupils enjoyed
watching it was a little slow but hey if
you never been on a date now you know
how to skate
maybe like if you're watching I really
appreciate all the support it's been an
awesome journey so far I think I don't
know how long it is that I'm curious
anyway I'll see you in the next one
regardless thousand brothers love you I
can swim